Naruto peut avoir neuf médiums karatsu
va voir ma chérie non à la sauce Inga Chuckster
prends un chariot kouhaku pas de contact
aujourd'hui mamita coton dans notre orteil moi à
dokuro
Subbarao shinobi sais pour que nous puissions tous
chanter des
bagages au club envoie-les en haut allons-
y
zenzen me chuck  ça O'Hara déclare la crise
lève-toi dans la salle de bain
un kilo tu y vas chérie Oh rit
ce soir sécurisez les exons
oh garçon drame sur ok pas de koto oh mon
astrologie seule Dakota bar chaque jour salut
la voiture rouge Akane
elle s'est présentée à American animal right
ennuyeux je suis  un orignal peut soit
ma mère est devenue Lewis ouais
le dernier Naruto le film
toi